let's go to the phones it has been a
while since we have taken phone calls
because the david pakman show summer
vacation but when we do take calls we
take them at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we'll go
to our first caller today from the 6 3 1
area code caller from 6 3 1 tell us your
name and what's on your mind today
hi my name is Dan I'm from Long Island
New York and my question is I know that
uh you know you kind of discussed the
idea of universal basic income but I
also heard of several ideas
say for example I would build and freed
and argued was that a negative income
negative income tax credit so uh I guess
my question is you would be um I guess
but are those generally like good
substitutes for the welfare programs we
have right now well there's a couple
different ways to think about this and
I've been reading a lot about this and
from from a bureaucratic perspective
universal basic income makes a lot of
sense because if you think about all
these different piecemeal welfare
programs that we have each often with
different means testing each with its
own bureaucracy of staff and
infrastructure if we could say let's get
rid of all of that and instead put in
place a non means-tested basic income
system that goes to everybody regardless
of income that we're going to be able to
deliver money to people much more
efficiently and you're also going to be
able to sort of disconnect from a lot of
this means-testing that is actually the
source of a lot of the controversy that
exists with welfare programs people
worried about Free Riders right the case
may be so that all makes absolute and
total sense to me
the area where I've been increasingly
reading more about ubi universal basic
income and become a little concerned
right is that it is still something
which you know when I started to see a
lot of super rich dudes start to talk
about universal basic income I initially
said
Wow that's really great because it's
really starting to go slightly
mainstream and then I realized that's
going to be a huge government
reallocation of money to some of these
huge companies in the sense that when
you have a means-tested food stamp
program that money is not going to
Microsoft or Facebook for example
however if you do eliminate all of these
welfare programs and then instead you
say hey one check universal basic income
spend it however you want there is going
to be and you can say hey listen you
can't be a nanny state if people decide
to buy upgrades for farmville on
Facebook which I know is not right
anymore or whatever instead of buying
food that's their problem it is going to
see a redistribution from for example
local grocery stores to some dot-com
companies and so that's one of my
concerns with it Dan right cuz I would
kind of ask you uh you know to sort of
follow up with that question um don't
you think that the the idea of kind of
having some sort of UDI whether it's
like say depending on your income level
like ten thousand dollars a year doesn't
that almost kind of incentivize people
to sort of smoke like you know not work
or expert less more less hours or you
know things like that yeah no I don't
think so and the reason why is unlike
for example unemployment benefits or
some other benefits that phase out as
your income grows it's guaranteed to
everyone so it would only be additive if
you are happy with your ten thousand
dollars a year then you can just keep
your ten thousand dollars a year and not
work the reality is most people if given
the opportunity to work and make another
twenty thousand dollars a year on top of
the ten thousand they're already getting
most people will choose to earn more
money and because it doesn't phase out
the that disincentive that exists
arguably at some levels with some
programs wouldn't exist but very good
questions and you're thinking about all
of the right issues here and we'll talk
about universal basic income again I
really appreciate the call